dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly fajir neural style
transfer just appeared four years ago in
2015
star transfer is an interesting problem
in machine learning research where we
have two input images one for content
and one for style and the output is our
content image reimagined with this new
style the cool part is that the content
can be a photo straight from our camera
and the style can be a painting which
leads to the super fan results that you
see here however most of these works are
about photos so what about video well
hold on to your papers because this new
work does this for video and the results
are marvelous the process goes as
follows we take a few keyframes from the
video and the algorithm propagates our
style to the remaining frames of the
video and wow those are some silky
smooth results in specific what I would
like you to take a look at is the
temporal coherence of the results proper
temporal coherence means that the
individual images within this video are
not made independently from each other
which would introduce a disturbing
flickering effect I see none of that
here which makes me very very happy and
now hold on to your papers again because
this technique does not use any kind of
AI no neural networks and other learning
algorithms were used here okay great no
AI but is it any better than it's AI
based competitors well look at this
hell yeah this method does this magic
through building a set of guide images
for instance a mass guide highlights the
stylized objects and sure enough we also
have a temporal guide that panel eise's
the algorithm for making too much of a
change from one frame to the next one
ensuring that the results will be smooth
make sure to have a look at the paper
for a more exhaustive description of
these guides now if we make a carefully
crafted mixture from these guide images
and plug them in to a previous algorithm
by the name stylet we talked about this
algorithm before in the series the link
is in the video description then we get
these results that made me fall out of
my chair I hope you will be more
prepared and held on to your papers let
me know in the comments and you know
what is even better you can try this
yourself because the authors made a
standalone tool available free of charge
just go to EB synth comm or just click
the link in the video description
let the experiments begin thanks for
watching and for your generous support
and I'll see you next time